hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
trump card or Joker in the pack is
Donald damaging the Grand Old Party
after 18 months of talks would a nuclear
deal with Iran make the world a safer
place and the grass sealing Team USA's
back on top of the world but do we have
equality on the pitch every man to mince
his words Donald Trump's comments about
Mexicans threatened to make mincemeat of
the Republican Latin vote in the last
few weeks the businessman has suggested
immigrants crossing the border into the
USA are bringing drugs crime even
disease the story rumbles on as Trump
defends his comments and his rivals
attack him for making them well as usual
let's bring in our special guests
Democrat commentator Jeffrey Robinson
and the conservative commentator
Armstrong Williams Jeffrey is Trump
really helping the GOP oh I thought
disclosure I know Donald and I like him
a lot he's a he's a very likable guy and
he was very generous to me when I wrote
a novel about his building on Fifth
Avenue it's a Harold F Harold Robbins
esque kind of novel called Trump Tower
and that's a naked plug and so Donald
and I get along very well is he gonna
get the nomination no do I agree with
what he says no will he become president
nobody's very good value he was actually
created by the conservative wing that
the Tea Party wing and he is exposing
the Republicans for what they are a
bunch of two-faced phonies I love him
I'm strong he's not doing the GOP any
favors is he doing lasting damage do you
think you know we're we're nation they
get so caught up in the soundbite and
what makes the headlines and the
international press follows suit without
digging any deeper and what he was
trying to convey because I certainly
don't believe that
a bigot erases that in his anti-mexican
I think he's what he was trying to do
was convey a deeper point when a lot of
these people who are in jail who just
happen to be some members of the Mexican
gangs and they kind of chehra that they
rein on people's lives it has been
documented within the last few days
about the rape and the terror and and
people wonder why Donald Trump continues
to soar on the in the polls among GOP
voters it's not because they're lost in
the sauce and don't understand what's
going on immigration is a real problem
we do not have what is necessary to vet
people that are crossing these borders
who coming in this country who find
themselves just easily integrating with
the rest of society but some of these
people a very small percentage of them
don't mean the society any good they
bring the same habits from where they're
from to our country and they wreak havoc
on people's lives and many of these
people in jail
I guess Donald Trump should have been a
little more eloquent about it but it's
becoming a real debate in the media and
I guess some of the media try to
sensationalize it in the beginning and
write it off as a jokester but he had
quite a lot of merit to what he was
trying to convey he just did not convey
it as well well okay I think we probably
agree on that but let me bring in Joe
Tuchman here who's joining us now from
Mexico City Joe welcome to our program
how have the comments gone down they're
extremely offensive and also untrue I
mean really the idea that it's easy to
cross the border hasn't been truthful
for many years now and it's been getting
increasingly difficult in the last few
years and the last miming Mexicans here
know that the last few of the vast
majority of Americans going to the
states are hardworking people just
looking for a way of supporting their
families but Mexico's not deny that
there are some nefarious elements I mean
you can argue about the percentages
there are some ne'er-do-wells getting
over the border and causing trouble in
America too out there yeah I think
anybody denies that but that's not what
Donald Trump said he said that and there
are some ice what was that the phrase
was something like I assume there are
also some good people I mean that's
extremely offensive
to the vast majority of Mexicans and
it's something also that powerful people
in Mexico can use to bring the country
together because it's so obviously
unfair the country that is very divided
on many issues including security and
including the the failure of the
government and of their economic system
to provide jobs for those migrants who
are leaving that's something that the
extremeness of those comments means that
those people can come together jeffrey
robinson it reminds everybody of any
persuasion I suppose of this porous
border issue is this gonna be a real
talking point to think over the next
twelve months oh it absolutely is I mean
I'm supposed perfectly right Donald
listen he fires from the hip and he and
he gets things wrong he's wrong about
Mexico of course and he can be very
offensive in his way of saying things
but he's absolutely right to bring up
immigration because the Republicans have
been avoiding it for two years instead
they wanted to obliterate Obamacare they
wanted to stop gay marriage they've been
on all sorts of social things and when
the chips are down they have failed
categorically failed to come up with a
satisfactory immigration solution and
Donald Trump is is showing those
fissures in their Republican policy
that's all he's totally right to bring
it up it is a huge problem the bore the
border is porous and I'm afraid that
just slightly wrong and that there are a
lot more undesirables coming across that
border with drugs bringing guns back
bringing money back it's it's got to be
stopped and there's got to be a solution
the Republicans simply don't want to
deal with it look at jeb Bush's wimpy
answer look at Marco Rubio's turnaround
on on immigration they're all a bunch of
wimps they're afraid to deal with it and
Donald is standing up and saying you
have to Armstrong is it the case the
American economy can withstand if not
actually need further immigration and
therefore the government of whatever hue
the next president whoever it is needs
to sort this out because in some sense
you need more people coming to America
don't you you know I think that's one of
the biggest myths in this country is
that everyday Americans are not willing
to take the jobs that many of these
migrant grass workers are willing to
take and that's just not true I mean
especially in their kind
economy that we're in now there are many
people that seek these jobs and and many
of these jobs are not available because
they're able to exploit these migrant
workers that paid them scraping the
barrel of wages or it's almost
impossible for someone to even have an
opportunity will compete for the jobs I
mean what they do they lower the the the
the the kind of money the standards and
what people should be making because
these people are equally explored it
many of them cannot expect in language
when you go to the hospitals oftentimes
they're misdiagnosed the lawyers use
them the people who are bring them in
this country I use them and not only
should we protect the American labor
force but we should also protect these
market workers that come here from being
further exploited and taken advantage of
there are many Americans that will work
these jobs yes these people bring
talents they bring gifts they're
hard-working maybe these people are
god-fearing people they're Christians
they go to church on Sunday they're
trustworthy and they do very good work
but it's not to say that they're not
Americans here who would not do the same
and bring the same to the workforce joke
my white just so many Mexicans still
want to make it to America what's the
incentive the primary incentive is the
lack of jobs or the lack of decent jobs
in in Mexico Mexico has been you know
about half the population lives in
poverty
there's the gross levels of extremely
mediocre when there is growth it's just
not kind of working it's not providing
enough jobs enough security for the
people of Mexico and that's why they go
there's also really a long tradition of
people going so there's there's that
there as well going and coming back and
going coming back and one of the main
issues about the increasingly difficult
border the increasingly closed border is
that that actually encourages organized
crime it puts migrants from the hands of
organized crime because it is so
difficult to cross Jeffery Robbins from
the Latino vote is much thought to be a
significant part of any election process
but where is the significance can any
president get elected without it well
the significance is in Florida for
example and in Arizona and in Texas and
in New Mexico Texas is becoming a purple
state it's if the Republicans are losing
their grasp on Texas because of the
Latino vote but Armstrong raises a point
which I really want to get back to and
it's the right point about these workers
and how they're being exploited one of
the things that needs to be done and
again the Republicans have avoided this
for the past two years they've
controlled Congress one of the things
that really needs to be done is to go
after the employers and stop them from
hiring illegal workers that can be done
and everybody should be able to agree on
that that will stop a lot of the problem
if these people can't get jobs many of
them will stop coming to America
illegally looking for those jobs get to
the employers in a sense follow the
money stop them from hiring illegal
workers under criminal penalty and some
of this will dry up yeah but that's the
sort of free market issues and I can't
see Armstrong working with you on that
can i Armstrong no and you know it's I
just find it fascinating that my brother
on the liberal side just wants to blame
this immigration and Lane at the
doorsteps of Republicans I mean the the
Democrats are just as bad as the
Republicans they all want that vote is
that whether or not that vote would make
it a difference they believe that vote
would make it differs and I think Jo and
I might agree on something this morning
most of these people for the most part
usually vote conservatives they have
very strong traditional values very
strong social values they are with the
Republican Party on many of the issues
it's just when it comes to these issues
that when it comes to immigration the
DREAM Act and obviously President Obama
passing the DREAM Act guarding a lot of
support for President Obama in his abase
but for the most part if you look at
Texas and you look at places like
Florida and even Ohio they're normally
the swing vote that makes the difference
for Republicans so I don't know what
Jeffrey is talking about that these
people are going to eventually in their
voting for Democrats know they vote
their values and their values are very
traditional not on this planet they're
not not on millionaire on different
planets
yeah absolutely because you look at the
Latino vote and they are not a
Republican vote they are absolutely not
that's why all the Republicans are so
worried about trying to come up with
Voter Registration Act which will
exclude them that's why you've got all
sorts of terrible programs aimed at
keeping them from the democratic process
because Texas for example is becoming a
purple state absolutely the Latino vote
is changing that
look at the politician okay let me let
me toss the same thought - I know your
speak to us from Mexico City what's your
take on how significant the relationship
with Mexico in general and the Latino
vote in particular will be in the next
year J often when Michael's leave Mexico
they've forgotten in Mexico apart from
the money they send back it's not in the
interests of for example the Mexican
government to make a big deal about
exocrine migrant rights in the US or the
Latino vote because in one way it
reflects very badly on Mexico not
because they're criminals and rapists
that are going but because they're
people who are escaping an untenable
situation within Mexico so the Mexican
government is actually very passive on
on migrants in within the financial
relationship and they say not nothing
ever about the Latino vote Jo Tupman in
Mexico thank you very much indeed
a reminder you can catch up with Sky
News debate on Apple TV on roku and
catch up and of course at Sky News com /
us now it's been 2 years in the making a
deal on Iran's nuclear future the West
promises an end to economic sanctions in
return for assurances that Tehran will
not develop nuclear weapons but can a
deal and a for in the relationship
between the west and Iran make the world
a safer place well let's speak to
Shaheen gebardi
from the National Council of resistance
of Iran that's a coalition of Iranian
opposition movements Shaheen is also a
thermonuclear engineer thank you for
being with us today this deal I guess
still not absolutely nailed down but
it's the objective to get a good deal is
the motive behind that the right motive
to have right now well thank you for
having me your program I should say one
has to have no illusions about the fact
that why we are today
look the Iranian regime has been
striving to obtain nuclear weapons for
the past almost three decades this
program has all the markings of a
weapons program and has all the
ingredients of a weapons program and
there is no other logical reason for the
Avena regime to be so insistent on
continuing this program because
according to the regime's own
assessments which have obtained this
does not make any sense economically so
having said this the man who has to make
the ultimate decision is Ali Khamenei
the Iranian regime Supreme Leader and
now why the talks have dragged on for so
long simply because Khamenei is in a
major deadlock is a major impasse for
the past two and a half decades he has
invested so much on obtaining nuclear
weapons as a guarantor for survival of
his regime on the other hand in the past
few years the economic sanctions have
started to biting and he realizes the
Iranian people are more restive than
ever and he's very much fearful of mass
uprising similar to what they witnessed
in 2009
so simply put his cut between a rock and
a hard place and that's why if I may use
the term he wants to have the cake and
eat it too what one yeah but
Shahin just doing just to interject here
he's not going to be allowed if we take
at face value what the negotiators are
telling us from John Kerry and everybody
else he's not gonna be able to have his
cake and eat it too is he well let me
bring in Jeffrey Robinson who's in New
York as you know and Armstrong Williams
in Washington at this point I'm strong
if our guest is right everyone the
president included is wasting their time
this isn't going to be a workable deal
you know dr. Shaheen is so refreshing
there's nothing that he said that I've
disagree with and even just add not to
taking everything away there no notice
inspection the elimination of the
current stockpile of its enrichment of
rhenium you got the term of the deal
which is going to be subject to the end
of this liquidation of the Iranian
program as an outline of that in NPT and
this and also and he makes this point
shank sanctions should be listed
progressively as Iranians showed that
their good behavior is validated they
don't want any of this and what they
what the Shaheen just said is so clear
their only goal is to the guarantee the
Khomeini what he's always promised that
they have nuclear weapons for their own
protection and their destruction of
others and it's just so frustrating to
watch these brilliant people like Kerry
and the president sit and negotiate with
these people who are laughing at them
who have no intentions of following the
guidelines their only agenda is to get
this enrichment be able to complete what
they've already started and we're gonna
become the laughingstock of the world
because what you're going to do you know
what is it going to end up happening is
you're gonna have a nuclear Middle East
because the Saudis are not gonna sit by
and why arraign gain this kind of
nuclear script strength the Israelis are
not gonna sit by and watch it I mean
it's a very dangerous situation for us
down the road Jeffrey why do you think
that persevering with the topes
I think they're persevering on the on
the hope against hopes that they can get
a real deal and a real deal would be
great I mean she he's absolutely right
and to some extent Armstrong is as well
it's what he's doing in saying that we'd
become the laughingstock of the world
that's that's when I had to get off the
boat
but the real deal would be terrific
because a real deal would mean full
inspections to guarantee that they were
not building a nuclear weapon I don't
think that's gonna happen I think that
carry and and the president and the
entire State Department staff who are in
many cases not political I'm not gonna
let the world be pulled over their eyes
we're not going to get a deal that goes
halfway and lift this actions it's it's
pretty much the only nothing and I'm
afraid it's gonna be nothing because she
and to that extent we're that Armstrong
is right are both right chinga body the
level of trust between what a lot of
countries and Iran actually is pretty
bad perhaps between America as a nation
and America's government and the Iranian
government is is very difficult to can
that even be overcome even off these
months and months of meetings and
summits you see one has to be very clear
here the key word here is transparency
not trust what do I mean the Iranian
regime should come clear with these past
military aspects of the nuclear program
and that's where they are fighting the
skillet in the closet because they know
if they allow snap inspections if they
allow you know verification system you
know people who find out that this is a
nuclear weapons program and basically
all their Bluffs will be called and
become real nature of this program be
known so that's why they keep on
repeating the word not trust building
trust building but the key phrase here
is transparency and as Madam Maryam
Rajavi the president-elect of the
Iranian resistance has said time and
over unless there is you know absolute
access to any side being military or
non-military access to the Iranian
scientist by the IAEA clearance on the
past military dimensions as long as you
know Iranian nuclear stockpot and
nuclear stock is transferred out of Iran
and as long as the UN Security Council
resolutions are implemented there is no
way you can guarantee that all the
pathways to the bomb has been closed and
if I may add another point very quickly
track record is very
here for the past two decades and
particularly past to 12 years that since
that the Iranian resistance and the
National Council of resistance of Iran
revealed existence of such a secret
program particularly Natanz and Iraq the
attitude of the political regime
vis-a-vis international community has
been hide and seek catch me if you can
you cannot find one single site that the
Iranian regime has voluntarily exported
IAEA you cannot won't find one project
that this regime has totally voluntarily
they only acknowledge them after they've
been cut you know completely red-handed
when other sources like the Opera Mini
resistance and others have caused so
much on them that there was no other
choice so what I'm saying is that this
kind of background talking about trust
is simply misplaced the issue here is
transparency and as I said unless these
measures are taken there's no way you
can guarantee that all the past page the
nuclear bomb is closed hey Jeffrey
Robinson would you trust the Iranians no
of course not there's no reason to trust
them transparency is great but Trust is
the result of transparency and this deal
is never going to get through Congress
if the trust factor isn't there
transparency is a big part of it but the
Iranians have shown absolutely no reason
to trust them and unless they come
forward with something concrete it's
just not gonna happen I don't think it's
a waste of time I think was worth the
try but I think we should we should have
any I hope yeah yeah and let's put that
point to Armstrong it's worth a try and
in a sense isn't the keeping talking
about it Armstrong better than not
talking about it at all and therefore
maybe they go ahead and build a nuke
anyway no because they're buying their
time and I think we should listen to dr.
Shaheen because what we have here is a
try factor every aspect of the agreement
fails not only on the key points but on
also on the meaningless points there are
no points where you find any victory or
anything that gives you hope from their
history to the transparency to the fact
of their stolen and to the fact why
they're doing this it's not because it's
a principled position they want to make
sure that they get a further grip of
in the middle-east and there we'll
analyze you see they don't operate from
the same principles of integrity and
keratin and honor and your word meaning
something that the West operates from it
does not exist that is the starting
point if we have if that is they don't
have that as a starting point then
there's nothing to discuss because
everything is based on your word and
their work over the past twelve years as
dr. Shaheen has said has been
meaningless so she hanging about is a
final thought they should all just pack
up and go home
well I think the rest and particularly
us has made too much concession already
the issue is what Iran has to be
rewarded for lying and cheating and
concealment and deception all these
years so I think any principle policy as
I said who look for somewhere else for
change the narrative that you either go
for bomb or you make a deal with the
mullahs I think is wrong narrative there
is another choice go for change from
inside Iran reach out to the Iranian
people which are to the Iranian
resistance for Democratic Change put to
change and and in my opinion the
ultimate solution is the regime change
in Iran by the Iranian people and the
organized resistance because the idea
that even if you make a deal with this
regime their policy is visibly their
transgression in the region there are
abuses inside the country the support
for terrorism is going to add I think is
delusional at best okay
the regime is not going to give up on
its pillars of power and I think by
giving them you know concessions and
loosening up sanctions you simply
embolden them your name change the
course chinga body thank you very much
indeed
thank you
next winners once more the u.s. women's
national team has taken home the World
Cup for the third time the players have
won the admiration of a nation with
record-breaking viewing figures in their
clash against Japan but can they now
claim equal ranking with their male
counterparts on the sports field has
women's sport reached equality let's
bring in Jeffrey and Armstrong Armstrong
you go first how the ladies doing in
your mind struggling and they struggle
because while they won the championship
they should be applauded you just don't
have the corporate sponsors around the
country that pay for it and nor are the
women filling the seats they just they
just can't not like the men who have the
sponsors we have the cachet and have a
just of just a throng of supports all
around the country I mean there are very
few sports of and where women involve
that truly generate the kind of pay that
men receive and the only exception
probably is golf and tennis I mean you
look at the Williams sisters too Rena
Williams and look at Maria Sharapova
those are two athletes that's on the
Forbes list of the highest-paid women in
the country it's because it's a global
sport global sponsorship they have a
brand people know who they are they're
following soccer does not have that
level of participation the market has
the dick take that and not just because
they're women but you've got to demand
that you play a calliper game that makes
it so scintillating that sponsors and
people around the world want to watch it
and fill the stadiums and that's just
not happening and Jeffrey I'm gonna take
another global game like golf for
instance the women get poorer purses
when they win good golf tournaments
don't they not only do they do that but
in wit tennis it was only until the
women put their foot down and said
you're a bunch of misogynist pigs that
you got to pay us the same kind of money
and still they don't now let me
straighten I'm strung out about the
numbers because he's dead wrong about
them
the fact is that 27 million people watch
the US team win the World Cup only 17
million people watched the Men's World
Cup final so the women scored 50% better
than that
more people in this country watch the
women's final than watched the seventh
game of last year's World Series or the
6th and deciding game this year of the
NBA or the Stanley Cup
women's soccer is the single most
popular women's game in the world the
men received eight million dollars
simply for showing up in Brazil and
losing the women got two million dollars
for winning it is absolute misogyny it
is their pigs FIFA is a bunch of pigs
Sunil Gulati who's head of the US soccer
who put the medals on these women
smiling with his phony garbage smile
knowing that he had forced them to play
on turf when they wouldn't dare do that
for the men knowing that there was
sponsorship knowing that they sold out
the stadium knowing what the viewing
figures were embrace them and said oh
well we will continue to treat you like
second-class citizens I will remind you
that Blatter said women to get a better
attendance if they were shorter uniforms
they I mean it is just disgusting the
way the women are treated they are
winners they have proved themselves
winners and there is money there really
is it has to do with the fact that there
are too many misogynist running soccer
to give them and I'm sorry even though
even over here in the good old you UK
there was an unfortunate tweet I think
about congratulation to our women's
soccer team they can now get now come
back to being mothers and daughters as
if their football didn't really add up
to very much it was worse than that more
it was worse than that when one of the
major newspapers in Britain made a
comment about it saying that anybody who
criticized the men's game in favor of
the women's game were sexist I mean that
disgusting reaction the women lizard
listen thank you sir listen what we just
witnessed with witness with women's
soccer is more the exception than the
rule you have you have moments like this
all the time in men's sports and in
men's soccer and and I know why some
people may find an offensive and that
personal minute to be offensive but
being a mother and raising children is
one of the highest honors and most
important jobs this world could ever
have so I think that is a high honor and
a compliment for men and women and men
who support their families and raise
good children who contribute to society
so I definitely don't see that as an
insult our offensive Jeffrey will have
to leave it there thank you for being
with us this week that's it for this
edition of the debate you can continue
watching sky news on Apple TV Roku on
ketchup and of course on Sky News calm
until next time goodbye